One of the world leaders most prominently
denying the reality of Corona virus has been
Brazilian President Gire Balsan.
He has now tested positive for Corona virus.
Now he's 65 years old.
He has trivialized the pandemic.
He would show up places either without a mask
or wearing a mask incorrectly in terms of
total cases in Brazil now.
They are second in the U.
In the world behind the United States in terms
of total deaths.
Brazil is now second in the world behind the
United States in terms of per capita.
They are also just below the United States
in both cases and deaths.
And Gyroball S.R.O. was bragging in March
that if he were to get the virus, he would
quickly fight it off and recover because he
has a history of being an athlete.
He then kept going to large events and to
gatherings without wearing a mask or again
wearing it incorrectly.
After announcing that he had tested positive
to reporters yesterday, he stepped back and
took off the mask and said, Look at my face.
I feel fine.
He was also recently with a bunch of his top
cabinet members.
Everybody was not wearing a mask.
Now I got messages from people saying, you
know, David, this could be the best thing
that happens to Brazil because.
This is going to change both scenarios, view
of Corona virus, because he got it himself.
I think you're very, very wrong, especially
if he fights it off.
He is going to be reinvigorated about how
this is really no big deal.
And, you know, statistically, he's probably
going to be fine because, again, most people
do not get very sick.
Even 65 year olds who are generally healthy
Here in Massachusetts, I believe the average
age of death from Corona virus is like 82
or something like that.
So in all likelihood, a relatively healthy
65 year old is going to be fine.
And if he is and he fights it off, it will
actually foment him further, downplaying it
with, you know, see, I told you so.
It wasn't really serious if he were to get
really sick.
It might change his view, but this guy seems
so off the wall, nuts and disconnected from
reality that it might still not make a difference.
And when I was looking online at the comments
about this, you know, a lot of people wishing
him harm, that is never my take.
I don't wish harm on anybody.
I'm recognizing the propaganda value of this.
And he even posted a video yesterday of himself
taking a pill, which he claimed was hydroxyl
chloroquine.
He was laughing in the video talking about
how great he feels and how the medication
is certainly working well and blah, blah,
blah.
It's all wacky propaganda.
I mean, he truly seems to have some kind of.
He has an unusual personality.
I don't want to diagnose anything, but it's
an unusual personality.
Now, the other thing about the more prominent
people who get Corona virus is it's believed
or known me put a different way.
There's speculation that when a prominent
person gets corona virus, they are immediately
getting access to antibody treatments.
When we've seen the success rate of these
antibody treatments where you take convalescent
plasma from people who have recovered and
have antibodies and you transfuse it into
a sick person, the reports I've seen so far
are that that is very, very effective.
And there's speculation I don't want to say
anything other than there's speculation that
when a prominent or wealthy person gets the
virus, they get access to that treatment,
which is not widely available because of the
limitations you have to harvest, collect plasma
from people who have recovered.
And that also may be increasing the success
in fighting off the virus for prominent or
wealthy people.
It's mere speculation.
That's the latest with the Brazilian president.
Gyroball.
Sayonara.